I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle welcome tonight and thanks for
joining us in Washington
shooting blanks that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
what does it take to get fired in this
Administration
provide Administration official is no
longer employed by the Biden
Administration after allegedly getting
caught stealing luggage from not one but
two different airports Sam Brenton was
responsible for nuclear fuel in
radioactive waste at the department of
energy he died Britain identifies as
non-binary and gender fluid
oh does he
talk about holding the bar really high
you know he'd still be there if they
didn't have that security footage by the
way
well for this Administration it's
failure as far as the eye can see yet
zero accountability none
still no senior officials no cabinet
official fired not Alejandro let them
all in my orcas at DHS not leave it to
Pete bootage at the Department of
Transportation
not the queen of transitory inflation
Janet Yellen at Treasury
so the only logical conclusion at this
point can be that America's decline is
their agenda
now Biden's balloon Fiasco was a
national embarrassment for the United
States at every turn and it reminds us
that we really don't have military
leaders who are looking out for us
even when generals Austin and Millie
blew the Afghanistan withdrawal which
led to the deaths of 13 service members
they still kept their jobs the Intel
assessments had two basic things in my
view was the the scale and scope plus
the speed all the Intel assessments all
of us got that wrong there's no question
about it that was a swing and a miss on
the Intel assessment
oh I'm singing a mess forget it now
in no other professional setting would
this be conceivable but at the top
levels of our defense department they
protect their own then they move on to
the next debacle and then they demand
that you support them unconditionally
War has evolved over the last 11 months
but the mission of under General
Lawson's leadership under secretary
Austin's leadership has remained the
same as much as it takes for as long as
it takes this isn't just about Ukraine's
security it's about the world that we
want our children and grandchildren to
inherit
oh the world well under their lame
leadership we're creating a world where
China doesn't just control all of Asia
it's making gains in our own hemisphere
including right here in the United
States
you see China's serious about its plans
for Domination and control
meanwhile Biden's chairman of the joint
Chief spends inordinate amounts of time
promoting awoke agenda within his own
ranks
on the issue of critical race Theory Etc
a lot of us have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is
um
but I do think it's important actually
for those of us in uniform to be
open-minded and be widely read and the
United States Military Academy is a
university and it is important that we
train and we understand uh and I I want
to understand white rage and I'm white
and I want to understand it
bet he never gets so indignant with the
Chinese though like before and after the
2020 election when he called to check in
with this Chinese counterpart
or did you not ask tell him that if we
were going to attack you would let him
know as part of that conversation I said
General Lee there's not going to be a
ward I said help generally I'll probably
give you a call but we're not going to
attack you
we know that the CCP doesn't fear them
or even respect them
now let's remember that the poison of
critical race theory is being taught at
our military academies today
and then there was their needless and
damaging vax mandates in the military
they were only recently dropped a tacit
admission of failure and now for all the
world to see the Pentagon looks foolish
and weak
rather than an active defender of the
American interest for days our military
kind of played the role of a passive
Observer it's trying to just brazenly
sucked up information about our most
sensitive military installations
you leave it up to the experts they make
the decision and then we should all
abide by the body let the experts in
this business of defense do their jobs
he does realize we don't live in a
military dictatorship right I don't know
well top military brass of course argued
that we should do nothing to stop the
balloon
it was my assessment
uh that this balloon did not present a
physical military threat to North
America this is under my NORAD hat
and therefore uh I could not take
immediate action because it was not
demonstrating hostile act or hostile
intent
but like Maverick and Top Gun Biden says
he always wanted to shoot it down once
it came over the United in the United
States from Canada I told the defense
department wanted to shoot it down as
soon as it was appropriate does this
change include it they concluded we
should not shoot it down over land was
not a serious threat we should wait till
we got across the water
what seems obvious is that the Biden
people had wanted to keep the entire
thing secret and hoped that the balloon
Fiasco would literally blow over
they wanted nothing to interfere with
secretary blinken's plan to beg
president XI for more engagement please
sir don't break off relations with us we
want to get closer to you but the truth
came out didn't it since last week the
pr Folks at the Pentagon who appear to
be the only competent people on the
staff there have been engaged in a flat
spin of desperation
We believe We mitigated uh the
intelligence capability of the of the
balloon at the same time increasing and
improving our ability uh to collect uh
intelligence and information from it
well at least one former Democrat
Secretary of Defense isn't buying this
the White House has said that a lot of
the information the Chinese might have
wanted were scrambled they didn't get
much of anything do you believe that if
they've got
a balloon that's that's hovering uh over
a military air base or a missile air
base and Gathering intelligence or
gathering signals you have to assume
that if it was an intelligence gathering
mission
that they were gathering important
information and if we want to protect
our national security we have to make
damn sure that our adversaries don't get
access to that kind of information
never thought I'd quote Leon Panetta on
the show but and of course the
administration even claimed that three
different Chinese balloons Flew Over
America during the Trump Administration
well more on that claim with former
Trump National Security adviser Robert
O'Brien later in the show
but bottom line no moderately
well-informed person believes our
Pentagon anymore
now what's the most likely scenario
think about it for a moment that Millie
and Austin outsmarted the Chinese
or that their Pals and the CCP
outsmarted them
I think we all know the answer
the truth is this Administration would
not care if a thousand balloons from
China spied on us just like they don't
care about the people who are being
murdered in China or the fentanyl that
China is sending to poison and kill our
people or the way China crushed freedom
in Hong Kong or the way China is
building the strongest military in the
world
they don't care about how China uses
Tick Tock to steal users data or how
China infiltrates our universities or
how it's buying up food companies real
estate farmland
so they certainly don't care about a
balloon they're just worried about the
political Fallout going into 2024
this White House the policy is never
wrong it's just the messaging
because it's obvious that their primary
goal is to protect their relationship
with China
well the angle then is not going to
bother trying to persuade the Biden
people anymore
so this one's for the hill Republicans
now back in 2006 if you're listening to
me on Fox Run the radio I was warning
you that the public I could hear it from
my listeners they were turning against
the war in Iraq and I'm warning you now
that GOP electorate and soon the
Democrats they love our troops but
they've had it with this pentagon
Millie and Austin are either incapable
or unwilling of safeguarding our
national interests and eventually the
voters will have their way
we pulled out of Vietnam we pulled out
of Iraq we pulled out of Afghanistan
and if you're a Republican and you're
really going to believe in the massive
defense budget we have today you better
get on the phone you better call Biden's
new chief of staff and you better tell
them that you will not be able to keep
writing blank checks for the Pentagon
unless some real changes are made
so no more money for woke nonsense no
more tolerating incompetence
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else